merci
switch around c'est mon retour dans un monde un
univers que j'ai touché en 2006
il y a 15 ans le film a eu un grand succès
et on a décidé de revenir au meilleur de
ses histoires moi aussi je suis dans Silent Hill le
film c'est l'histoire  d'un jeune homme
revenant à Silent Hill où il a connu un
grand amour et ce qu'il va trouver
est un pur cauchemar j'ai la chance d'
être très proche de Kristoff et nous
avons réussi ensemble à convaincre
Konami qu'il y a un nouveau  version de
Silent Hill qui doit être faite et
ils sont 100 à bord
dans la première île ici, nous
explorions un monde dans lequel le monde de cette
petite ville se fermait complètement dans
la brume, c'était comme être piégé dans
une zone crépusculaire mais dans la seconde  jeu
vous savez que le secret du jeu a
changé les règles vous savez que
nous retournions essentiellement à Silent Hill dans la même ville
mais nous recherchions cet étrange monde
antar Leaf était le point de vue du
héros auquel nous jouions
pourriez-vous vraiment être dans ce  remorquer  n vous
rendez-vous compte que Marie est perdue quelque part dans
cet endroit étrange en son cœur c'est aussi
l'idée de la viande d'Orphée et
tout ce qu'un homme peut aller au plus profond de l'enfer pour
ramener l'âme ou la personne qu'il
aime le plus dans sa vie alors  c'est beaucoup
plus psychologique ou même si
on va retrouver tous la même
créature et la même étrange
séquence quelque chose comme ça mais le
premier grand interrogatoire et la première
grande terreur concerne nous
-mêmes sommes-nous fous
sommes-nous en sécurité
disons-nous  revenir à signer
jusqu'à trouver ce grand amour
celui-ci a maintenant tellement d'années depuis le
premier qu'il y a une idée claire
de Christoph pour le rendre moderne mais
aussi très fidèle au jeu vidéo et
c'est aussi ce que nous sommes
respectant également la volonté de l'auteur les
producteurs et Konami dans cette
adaptation Kristoff c'est vraiment quelqu'un
qui respecte le travail qui a été
fait mais qui a aussi sa propre Vision il
nourrit la Vision Créative des
auteurs du  jeu mais avec une
vision différente d'un cinéaste et
tous les deux ils ont créé je crois
quelque chose qui a frappé l'esprit
des fans
arrête de la
laisser tranquille c'est un jeu de Silent
Hill from cheese nous sommes une grande
réussite artistique et j'ai la responsabilité
de transposer ça  sur grand écran, vous
savez que Kristoff est le vrai joueur, il a
été immergé dans ce monde, c'est pourquoi
le premier film a été si bien accueilli par
les fans de Silent Hill car ils ont estimé
que j'étais l'un d'eux et c'était si
important pour moi de  respecter la
création originale tu sais que c'était
la base le début de tout
tout part de ce respect donc
j'y vais avec un maximum d'humilité un
maximum de respect mais en même temps
j'ai pas mal de charge pas mal d'objectif qui
est  comment transposer le langage du
jeu qui est entièrement question d'immersion
dans le récit en une histoire que l'on pourra vous
raconter en 90 sur un de vos rêves
les monstres sont aussi un des éléments clé
que le  les fans attendent
et nous les mettons à jour de manière à ce que
la création soit similaire mais ils seront
frappants pour moi l'un de mes principaux objectifs dans
ce film est de savoir comment repenser
le monstre classique de Silent Hill
je parlais de ma pyramide vous savez
ce mec avec internet vous savez qu'il
est encore dans celui-ci certaines des
créatures du film de retour en 2006
étaient très très appréciées par la famille
mais en même temps pour moi
c'était important de revenir avec la
surprise c'est  un nouvel univers c'est un nouveau
défi et ceux-ci sont très importants
pour amener ces icônes différemment au
public car ils veulent qu'elles aient
cet effet wow c'est pourquoi vous savez que j'ai
trouvé une collaboration très intéressante
avec les gens de Konami ils
m'ont beaucoup aidé à  réaliser ce nouveau design du
monstre car nous travaillons également sur un
nouvel épisode pour la franchise de Silent
Hill
le jeune public qu'ils veulent cette
expérience collective qu'ils veulent être
avec leurs amis qu'ils veulent  d'en
parler mais ils veulent aussi vivre cette
expérience ensemble nous savons tous que
regarder un film oral seul chez lui
est assez différent d'être dans un grand
théâtre avec une foule et tout le monde
saute en même temps
c'est très différent nous nous modernisons
nous lui donnons ce que le public d'
aujourd'hui veut vraiment nous essayons de
faire autant que possible créer une nouvelle
expérience pour ce public pourrait être
plus immersive et interactive et nous avons
maintenant de nouvelles technologies mais nous avons toujours
ce qui fait le mieux c'est l'histoire  et
cette histoire est au cœur donc on espère
que le retour à Silent Hill sera un
grand retour
et si on veut garder le lien avec le
public vous savez il faut être
parfaitement conscient que tout a
changé en 15 ans tout a été
emporté tu sais qu'on doit
ramener quelque chose tu sais très surprenant